من بيروت ينضم الينا العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي سيد امين
واضح من الكلام بوتن واسراره على ان
الاراضي التي ضمتها روسيا من اوكرانيا
المقاطعات الاربعه هي اراضي تاريخيا روسيا
وبان ما تقوم به روسيا الان هو حمايه
شعبها هناك وهذا طبعا يناقي تماما ما
يقوله زيننسكي ويقوله الاكرانيون الى اي
حد فعلا سيكون العام القادم كما قال
ديميترميديف عاما صعبا للطرفين
او العام الحالي طبعا عبد الصمد عند عبد
الصمد الرئيس بوتين حدد اليه النصر منظومه
النصر او نظريه النصر بالنسبه له يتحدث عن
الاستقلال يتحدث عن السياده يتحدث عن
الاراضي التاريخيه حقا له يعني يتحدث عن
اربعه اقاليم ضمها بمرسوم قسم منها يعني
الدنيا ليست كله تحت السيطره الروسيه
ايضا وخلسون يعني هذا امر يدل ان المرحله
القادمه هي مرحله محاوله استرداد هذه
الاراضي التي تعتبر حسب العقل الروسي
الخطاب او الرئيس بوتين وحتى وزير الدفاع
انها اراضي روسيه من هنا موضوع السياده
والمفهوم يعني هناك خطاب يحدد النصر
وبالتالي هناك عمليه تنفيذ في العمل 23
الميدانيه ما الذي ترسمه بخصوص ما هو قادم
حول شكل هذه
والي استراتيجيه ان كانت ستختلف عن مكان
سائدا في الاشهر الاخيره
مريم كل شيء يتعلق بالتكتيك بالامكانيات
ليوم الحديث بالتقرير الذي
قبل اللقاء ان ال اسكندر والصواريخ نتحدث
عن المخزون هل فعلا لدى روسيه مخزون كافي
لاسترداد القصف الجوي لا ينفع ما يحسم
المعركه هو السيطره على الارض يعني هناك
معدله لدى الرئيس بوتين يعني هو يقصف
اوكرانيا هو في وقت واحد يستنزف المخزون
الروسي
ويستنزف المخزون الدفاعي الاوكراني الذي
يموله الغرب وبالتالي ليس له من مردود
اساسي لانه بنك الاهداف لاوكرانيا وحتى
بكيا اصبح فارغا يعني دمرت كل من التحتيه
اللهم الا اذا كان الهدف لشيء ما يحد الله
في المستقبل
الهدف مثلا
الهدف هو ضرب العمق ضرب القدره على
الاستمرار اختبار الغرب خلق ازمه لاجئين
للغرب وبالتالي هل سيفعل الغرب وسيستمر
بالدعم الاساسي
ولكن العام 2023 عبد الصمد قد يكون عام
خلق التكتيكات الجديده يعني اليوم نتحدث
عن صاروخ ايرس على سبيل المثال 400,000
دولار مقابل شاهد 20 الف دولار اليوم هناك
محاوله اوكرانيه لخلق ااه مسيره تحارب
مسيره وهي قلبي كثير من العشرين الف دولار
تستعمل فيها همم ستارلينج التي يمومها الى
ماسك ما انا بخصوص ربما الاستراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه في هذه الحرب سيما مع هذه
السيارات التي ذكرتها التي وصل عدد منها
في الايام الاخيره الى قاعده انجلز
العسكريه في روسيا ما المتوقع بخصوص ما لك
يا بان تنتهي جه من اجل تحقيق نصرهاها
ايضا
موضوع النصر مريم ليس هناك من نص كامل
وشامل يجب ان يصل الافرقه الى درجه يعتبر
فيها كل فريق انه هذا اقصى ما يصل اليه
وبالتالي قادر على تسويق في الداخل هذه
المرحله
ولكن موضوع القصف في العمق الروسي هذا نمط
بدا يتكرر وبدا يصبح نمط معيانا لتقول
اوكراني انه يمكن نقل الحرب الى الداخل
الروسي التاثير على الراي العام وبالتالي
ضرب القواعد التي تنطلق منها القذائف على
اوكرانيا لكن بالنسبه للغرب طبعا هو يعيش
ازمه اقتصاديه ازمه طاقه يعيش ايضا تصدع
ماء الى حد نقول في المواقف في مواجهه
روسيا وبالتالي هل الغرب همم يعني واصل
دعمه لاوكرانيا بشكل المطلوب بشكل الذي
يسمح لاوكرانيا بصمود
عبد الصمد عندما قال زنسكي بالكونجرس ان
ما تعطون اياه ليس منا انه واجب يعني هناك
اهداف جيو سياسيه مهمه للغرب والعام 2023
هو عامل زي البوليتيك او الجيو سياسه
يتقدم على الاقتصاد وعلى كل شيء فلنتامل
لو ربح الرئيس بوتين واخذ كل اوكرانيا كيف
كان ليكون عليه الغرب النيته وحتى الصين
مع تايوان هناك يعتبر رئيس انه واجب الغرب
ان يساعده شكرا
خبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت